I would like to know Florida is one of
the most difficult states to vote in how
is it difficult exactly you have to
scale a rock climbing wall to get up to
the poles are the poles perched at the
top of some sort of precipice you have
to climb up to it is that how it works
or do they have you know is it like a
ballot on a kind of a a dart board and
you have to stand
10 yards back and throw your Dart and
hope that it hits the candidate you want
I mean that would count as difficult to
vote but also make voting a lot more fun
is that how it works in Florida I don't
know maybe someone could fill me in if
those are if those are the policies but
I'm pretty sure it doesn't work that way
and if you want to vote you could just
go and vote like anybody and it's
incredibly easy